um well we know Chris Brown's on the
album anybody else on the album I'm sure
there's tons of features let's be honest
but can you share any one is driving
what do you want us to drop it where you
can talk about the features
we could drop it whenever oh uh
when you when you're dropping the
tracklist
you're so good I got um
I got the The veto on the tracklist
shout out to him yeah my man Fireboy and
by the way David O is how you say his
name oh yeah I say DeVito I thought I
thought listen I interviewed him and I
watched a bunch of interviews with him
from Africa and they were saying David
oh so when I said David oh he was like
you said my name right and I was like
man I was like yes cause I thought it
was DeVito yeah
man you got that [__] afrobeat Gods
right now that that taliban's is going
crazy right now yeah I got them boys on
there who else on there
in Maverick City I don't know I'm not
familiar with Matthew there's a gospel
group it's like a choir oh fire I got
them on the intro there it's crazy over
many rappers
no no rappers wow I might I might throw
somebody on like a remix I had I had
some rappers I wanted on there but you
know what I'm saying time is timing
um well hopefully you don't like some
remixes that's crazy yeah I like so is
is the afrobeat tongue is everybody on
the on the same song or do you have
multiple I got multiple fire yeah that's
like that's like my um Second Home like
music wise I ain't gonna cat because I'm
Haitian so
they're like afro will be feeling
is just in me it's the funny genre it's
like finally there's music that people
can dance to happening like on a
mainstream level you know for sure it's
like the best part of the club night is
when like DJ yeah because people are
having fun they're saying about it's
like shout out to March Madness I love
it but I've been hearing it for like 10
years it's like yeah I could pop bottles
to that but like I'm not gonna dance to
it enough
so for you like uh let's break that
because because you're one of the hook
guys now who would you say is like a
Mount Rushmore of the best hook man of
all time who's the hook gods
my hood Gods Nate Dogg Nate Dogg is I
feel like Undisputed top number one slot
right yeah
then I'm gonna go to um
a little Chris Brown
and of course I'm gonna go to Ty Dollar
shout out to Ty
and then I'm gonna go to at the tie
I'm gonna go to Sanford
oh yeah like not even though he did a
lot of hooks but but the ones he did
[__] everybody up
tip on them right now like I think back
to uh the video of like when Marlo met
him artists
and I just remember being like damn I
really need to dive into this guy's
[__] catalog if he's making grown man
cry out here you make a real music bro
like
a lot of [__] be overshadowed but
the music the real music be put in the
back a lot nowadays but when you tap in
like a [__] like Samford that [__]
special bro I was gonna say like uh what
what was it like growing up in Philly
for you because we kind of hear so much
you know my co-host DJ damages from
Philly
and he would always tell me like about
North Philly and places like Chester
Pennsylvania and just like yeah just
like Phillies like that just that area
in general wow place and there's a lot
of videos that have been going viral
recently of like
because at fat Nosh it's really bad yeah
right you've probably seen the videos of
people like slumped out like looking
like zombies all over the street and
[__] out there yeah that's right that's
like near where I'm from a little bit by
the way also Happening Here in LA but
you know he
um but what was it like for you growing
up in Philly I mean obviously you you
were going to church and you know I'm
sure you were you had a a great
childhood but like was it was it I mean
easier or hard for you to deal with like
kind of
staying out of that [__] you know church
was in the trenches yeah like my pop
church was in the trenches bro so it was
like it's not like I had an easy
childhood like [__] as soon as you step
out of church it might be a shoot up
type [__] that's what I mean but you
were able to kind of keep it's kind of
like you gotta like
it's a rough neighborhood bro it's easy
to like fall into like it's easy to get
mixed up into that lifestyle right
and it's like you really just gotta stay
out the way mm-hmm like
just stay out the way bro like because
it'll be like you'd be in the way not
even on some dumb [__] you just be in
the way some crazy because where you're
at yeah just like you're at the wrong
place at the right time so what I will
say like I was always focused on music
like everybody knew me I asked fried I
want some music [__] like you know what
I'm saying like I used to engineer
[__] in Philly produce for [__] like
on some studio [__] yeah I'm saying so
it was just like I was always on some
music [__] and out the way forever so
it's definitely like a rough City though
but you really gotta like just stay out
you gotta be focused you gotta be
focused for sure so you don't get fall
into you know yeah
um what do you how do you feel about the
other Trend that's happened in the
Philly right now if you think a guy's
like too rare and just like the dance
[__] is going crazy like they have
anyway bro they're having a way yeah
they have an oil like it's beautiful bro
to see who's a good kid you guys just
signed
I'm just like
it's like everybody's kind of doing
their own version of the Philly thing
everybody having fun bro like they
brought in like a a fun vibe fun energy
that was missing and that's why like
afrobeat doing what it's doing like you
be in the club
all these songs about killing and [__]
all this afro [__] come on [__] Just
Wanna Have Fun and dance bro like I feel
that's why afrobe doing so good and even
the uh [__] from Philly like they
bring in like Good Vibes back I mean I'm
thinking like even night obviously uzi's
from Philly right so Uzi like doing just
want to rock
it's like the biggest song in the club
for like a year yeah and it's like just
this fun song like
fun music bro and them regular [__]
too From The Trenches too so like don't
get it like you know what I'm saying
like them they just decided yeah they
focusing on the right [__] like we don't
gotta be on those Street [__] making
songs about violence and all that they
just having fun bro did you ever like uh
tap in with like uh like obviously prior
to your generation but did you ever dive
into any of the roots of music back from
back in the day
uh uh a little bit like black Cloud's
one of the greatest rappers that ever
walk on the planet you know I wasn't
really on that but I wasn't on that
though but I'm familiar like I know
they're Legends you got a [__] request
love haven't played drums on a song or
something I know Questlove you know he's
still in the drums just like yo be an
honor man come and play drums on this
you know just for Philly yeah for sure
but I wasn't really on them early like I
mean you weren't on them early because
you also weren't alive exactly because
being on them early would have been you
were listening to them
because I think their first album was
like 92.
yeah
a lot of and that album isn't even on
Spotify you got to buy it like on a a
real the real jump yeah it's like yeah
and then you know Scott Storage yeah
Focus story he was in the roots for real
that's crazy I knew that somebody told
me that that's what started in the roots
yeah Legend you got to get with storage
man have you have you gotten in with him
yet no not yet he's a legend though let
him tell you some stories now I know he
got some crazy asses the craziest ever
any girl that you think of when I say
this to you right now that pops in your
head
he is true he [__] everybody first so
whatever girls just popped up in your
head yep then everybody everybody
we gotta sit down with skorts gotta go
out to Miami he's going when I heard he
went stupid when he was up and then he
went down but he's back up you back up
right now though yeah he got through it
I heard that story like he used to snack
the amount of money Sky Sports was
spending on just like everything was
just in I mean Jesus Christ God bless
that guy I'm just a legend his cousin
Mark [__] with squish we be having a
argument like who better Timbo or Scorch
I'll be going with Timbo
I think Tim was a I think it's like
Timberland's like top three ever so his
range is insane
he could do Bubba Sparks he could do it
I mean he could do it Nelly Furtado like
that's why he my favorite yeah the the
range of uh of him is insane how you
have you heard anybody try to make an AI
version of yourself yet
no I'm waiting it's gonna happen yeah
I'm waiting I want to hear it though
like yeah like can AI nail your your
tone you know
I mean ain't nothing some others crazy
[__] they are Ellen Rihanna Kanye the
Rihanna Tim's remix that [__] crazy it's
a fire yeah
I seen some other [__] it was uh
I think it was Kanye Franco Kanye single
Frank Ocean no Kanye Sunday Justin
Bieber
yeah that [__] was crazy though
yeah it's kind of crazy the AI thing is
getting a little it's getting a little
sketch I hope they I hope they shut that
[__] down though they're not going to
the labels are going to start [__]
doing the same [__] the actors are doing
you see why the actors are on strike
yeah cause they're trying to slide in a
little artificial intelligence into the
movies yeah so like extras like they
want the extras to be like AI like they
want to be able to scan like an actor
and then use their artificial likeliness
let's go it's coming bruh [__] uh
I think the some bull made a song like
Drake featuring The Weekend that [__]
hit like a million the first time oh
yeah yeah that's this was like yeah this
was like what maybe like six months ago
seven months yeah it was recent and that
[__] was that [__] went viral they like
this [__] hard because it's like also
not a bad idea if you're a writer I
wonder if it's a terrible idea to like
right who's on there right now right is
doing all AI [__] cause like this is
what this is like let me send this out
so like my thing is if you're a writer
and you write a song for Drake do you
send the AI Drake version to his team so
he back look this is how he would sound
I've seen some [__] like I I don't link
with some Rider they got some [__] I can
imagine man like they're not even
writing they ain't boyfriend